[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter good day martin are you
well i'm very fine thank you
good let's open with a word of prayer
hi heavenly father we've asked that you
enlighten our minds bless us with the
holy spirit and this in this discussion
and thank you for
allowing us to do this in jesus name
amen
martin we are living in the last days
i also believe
that
we are speedily heading
for the climax of the age
therefore it is important that we
understand the issues around
the close of probation
the latter rain
and everything that pertains to that so
we had two programs in orona where we
discussed current events where we looked
at
the issues in the news the ukraine
russia all of these things
but we always want to make sure that we
do not lose our spiritual foothold
correct
so we want to look at the gospel of john
and
many years ago not many years ago about
four years ago five years ago
time flies man
i gave a sermon that was titled for your
ears only
and
we want to look at what that actually
pertains to
with regards to the gospel of john
but before we get there
let's just first talk about the
significance
of the disciples
and the message that they bore
i don't know martin whether everybody is
aware of it but originally the sequence
of the books in the new testament
wasn't the same as it is today
so if you take your bible
and you look at the new testament
you know you have a particular sequence
you have the gospels and then you have
the book of acts
and today you start then immediately
with the writings of paul yes and then
right at the end you have
the books of
james
and peter
and
the epistles of john
and jude yes
now originally they were not at the back
they followed immediately after the book
of acts
so why they actually changed it is is a
bit of a mystery
but the original sequence is actually
quite significant
not that it changes the content of the
word of god
but it changes
the
let's how shall i put this it changes
the thoughts
and the deliberations
because paul is the theologian who
brings out the typologies
but
the elders
james and john
they were the ones and peter
that were basically giving the directive
for how things should be understood in
the future and they were right after
jesus ascended to heaven correct so paul
came later three and a half years later
and half years later so this was the
message that was for the church yes
so when we look at the original order of
the new testament books when the new
testament was originally canonized by
the apostles peter
paul and john
and that is an important aspect as well
you know because people think that some
church put it together
or the catholic church gave us
the sequences and all of these things
nothing could be further from the truth
long before
there was a catholic church
there was an
apostle paul peter and john
and they put together
the canon of the new testament
then the general epistles were placed
after the book of acts and before the
epistle of romans
now the general epistles are the ones
that refer to the writings of peter and
john and james
and jude
so the epistles james
first and second peter
first second and third john and jude
thus immediately followed the book of
acts and the byzantine text still
follows this order
so it's just interesting
it doesn't change the word of god it
just changes your mindset in terms of
how you are prepared for what is coming
next correct it's like when you read a
book
a novel
and you start in the middle and then go
to the beginning and then to the end
you can get the just of it but it might
change your mindset a little bit on it
very well put
so if this order had been retained there
would have been less confusion regarding
the issue of law and grace
because if you jump right into paul
then you can become confused and let's
face it i believe the world is very
confused that's exactly what happened
the proof of the pudding is in the
eating right well if you look at
basically the christian world
very rarely people actually do study the
other books they mainly study paul
so that shows you
that the if if the other
they will probably get confused
because of the way that paul puts
everything regarding the law yes if you
had a very clear statement
by the apostles and then you had the
explanations and the writings of paul
then you wouldn't lose your perspective
that easily
so one of the issues that is very
important is obedience
to the law of god
because the law of god is the standard
of judgment yes and it's also the
standard on which sin is determined yes
because sin is transgression of the law
there isn't the government in the world
that doesn't base its justice system on
law
so if we had a look at
the pistols of james
and peter and john
then we can see that they played a very
important role in bringing this emphasis
to the fall
so just a few examples
in james 1 25 we read but whosoever
looketh into the perfect law of liberty
and continueth therein he being not a
forgetful hearer but a doer of the work
this man shall be blessed in his deed
so he places quite an emphasis on
obedience
but also if you put it like this
they were putting the law back into its
rightful place because the
the leaders of the church at that stage
totally distorted it yes
chapter 2 verse 9 he says but if you
have respect to persons you commit sin
and are convinced of the law as
transgressors now this is a very
important
statement here
in other words what james is saying
don't listen to what
the people are saying
don't listen to what the pharisees are
saying
but listen to what the word of god is
don't be a respecter of persons
preaching is important
but it's only of value if it is in
harmony with the word of god that's it
you know
because people get so hooked up on
people
that when those people disappoint them
they throw the baby out with the bath
water and suddenly they don't believe
anymore
no your your anchor must be the word of
god your anchor mustn't be a martin
smith or a walter fight or
whoever out there in the world the
anchor is the word of god
and should
we just become totally apostate one day
doesn't change the word of god at all
not at all and the same with um like we
have always mentioned if there's
apostasy in a church it doesn't
necessarily make the whole church a
pastor no and it doesn't negate the
truth
so don't be a respecter of persons but
be convinced by the law
because you can easily become a
transgressor
by following a person yeah if that
person is very convincing i mean look at
the devil how convincing he was right
exactly you've heard of the angels
even though if you follow the spirit
it can be totally
wrong if you don't if the spirit is not
according to the law to the law and to
the testimony that's the whole bible
so
verse 10 says whosoever shall keep the
whole law and yet offend in one point he
is guilty of all for he that said do not
commit adultery said also do not kill
someone let's be very specific what law
is you referring to here ten
commandments ten commandments definitely
now if they commit no adultery he yet
thou kill thou become a transgressor of
the law
and i thought about that many times
if you covet
that's what the devil did in heaven it
started with the transgression of the
tenth commandment he coveted the
position of christ
if you covet that's breaking the tenth
commandment
so if you want to be in that position
you actually want to place yourself
there then you're actually breaking the
first commandment you shall have no
other gods beside me yep all right
that's it and that is a species of
idolatry that's breaking the second
commandment that is a blasphemy against
god that's breaking the third
commandment
if you then start tampering with the
authority of god
and questioning the authority of god
then you're breaking the fourth
commandment
and
god was his parent he's breaking the
fifth commandment
eventually you become so enraged that
you're willing to actually kill your
parent which the devil actually did at
the cross he killed jesus christ
who was his creator
therefore he broke the sixth commandment
yeah did he create spiritual adultery
yes did he break there for the seventh
commandment was he a liar and a thief
from the beginning they broke the eighth
and the ninth you start with the tenth
you break them all that's it
okay
so speak ye and so do as they that shall
be judged by the law of liberty so you
know this this epistle
was immediately after the book of acts
that sets the tone that's it
and then if you read paul
and it said it is by faith and not by
works that you are saved then it has to
be read in the context of this exactly
that's why martin luther said
anyone that can marry james and paul
in the sense of understanding how they
get together
will understand how
grace works yes so it's very important
and this sequence
is therefore rather sad that it has been
changed right
of chapter 4 verse 11 speak not evil one
of another brethren he that speaketh
evil of his brother and judges his
brother speaketh evil of the law
and judges the law but if thou judge the
law thou not a doer of the law
but a judge
that's also a very interesting verse so
you know you can become such a stickler
in the law
like the pharisees did that you set
yourself up as judge
you start looking at your brothers and
your sisters and you start saying
they're law breakers
but we're all
have our foibles right yes and if we
have very strict definitions that aren't
necessarily based on the word of god but
upon our
opinions like the pharisees had
then everybody who doesn't do things
exactly like you do them becomes a law
breaker
so let's leave the judgment to god god
yes so this is a very balanced view that
james portrays here
if we go to peter
there was also there in the beginning
it says in first peter chapter 4 verse
17 for the time has come that judgment
must begin at the house of god
and if it first begin at us what shall
the end be of them that obey not the
gospel of god
so obedience was it important to peter
oh definitely
and he said start with me
and then he has this very interesting
verse that most people would rather not
have in the bible
and if the righteous scarcely be saved
where shall the ungodly and the sinner
appear
in other words trade lightly yeah don't
be presumptuous and think oh i'm
standing on holy ground i'm fine
that word presumption
second peter chapter one verse three
according as his divine power has given
unto us all things that pertain unto
life and godliness
through the knowledge of him that has
called us to glory and virtue
does this entail a changed life yes so
you can't cannot just
pronounce that i'm changed your works
and fruits have to follow so in other
words you can't say jesus paid at all
all to him i oh there's nothing left for
me to do except relax right
no
you're not only called to glory which is
the character and the righteousness of
christ you're also called to virtue you
better do something
second peter 2 21
for it had been better for them not to
have known the way of righteousness than
after they had known it to turn from the
holy commandment delivered unto them
that's pretty straightforward
you cannot twist that one no
so in other words
it would have been better not to have
known the righteousness than to turn
your back upon
what has been delivered in terms of
obedience and all of those issues and
virtue but the bible is interesting
because can you not now say it's better
not to evangelize because if they never
knew
they were they would have been saved
yes but if they never knew
they were probably or most likely in a
very high probability
lost but there's also a verse in the
bible that says
if you don't tell them their blood be on
you
that's very interesting
you know
there's also a statement in the spirit
of prophecy which says almost
but not wholly saved
is to be not almost but totally lost
that's pretty well put
then let's go to john well let's first
look at the gospel of john
this is jesus speaking
he that has my commandments and keepeth
them
he at ease that loveth me and he that
loveth me shall be loved of my father
and i will love him and i will manifest
myself to him
that's a promise yeah
so if you want jesus to manifest himself
make known his principles
well then you better keep the
commandments right
and it's also important to remember here
he
is the one
that empowers you to keep his own
commandments and then he can manifest
himself yes
now let's listen to the words of john
himself in first john he that says i
know him and keepeth not his
commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him
now martin if you had read the bible in
this in this original sequence and you
come across these things
would you then be confused when paul
says you're not saved by the law but you
are saved by grace no because now you'll
know okay this is how important the law
is so when paul says that he's mean
making it
or telling you don't let you this become
a human activity
about keeping the law
it must be a godly manifested activity
all right let's go to the book of jude
which was the next one beloved when i
gave all diligence to write unto you of
the common salvation it was needful for
me to write unto you and exalt you that
you should earnestly contend for the
faith
which was once delivered unto the saints
for there are certain men crept in
unawares who were before of old ordained
to condemnation ungodly men turning the
grace of our god into lasciviousness
and denying the only lord god and our
lord jesus christ so can you change
the grace of god into something that is
condemnable
unfortunately people do
they do change
into
condemnation
yes so these are the ones that followed
immediately after the gospel
and they're pretty plain yeah
now let's go to the gospel of john
because i find
the gospel of john so fascinating
this is something that might summarize
it a little bit the gospel of john is
unlike the synoptic gospels
so the gospels of matthew mark and luke
or the synoptic gospel gospels and there
are basically eyewitness accounts
and a bit of history
that tell you exactly what transpired
and many of the teachings
and the way in which jesus worked are
supported by three witnesses
by two or three witnesses
shall every word be established right
but the gospel of john is totally
different
because it it's largely concerned with
the last week
of jesus on earth
and contains many portions which are not
mentioned by the us other gospel writers
the gospel of john relates no parables
that's interesting in itself right yeah
it relates seven of the miracles of
jesus of which only two
the feeding of the five thousand and the
walking on the sea are in the other
gospels
that's interesting yeah
the miracles related by john testify to
the divinity of christ in a special
sense
so the gospel of john has a different
emphasis
it emphasizes the divinity of christ
and it has a very special message
for
those that will receive
the former reign yes and by implication
the latter rain yes
the water to wine
speaks of the special cleansing
that's also a very interesting story in
the bible
because when he changed the water into
wine many people use this as a license
to
imbibe in beverages
which has nothing to do with it
whatsoever
exactly because the water
that was used was filled into the
cleansing vats
where they did uh ceremonial cleansing
washing of the hands and washing of the
feet
which was a ceremonial
cleansing
so that is the water that he used those
stone jars that were outside and that
had taps for cleaning your hands and
your feet
he filled those with water and change
that water into wine representing his
blood that's it
so
what he was basically doing was saying
there would be a higher cleansing than
the cleansing of this water yes
and if you do not imbibe in that higher
cleansing you have no part in him yes so
it's a it's a brilliant miracle
which can be brought down to the level
of the mundane if you ignore the
typology
and if you just use your logic and you
do a little bit of
research you'll see that those jars
represented approximately probably 800
liters of water yes so if you take in
jesus during
the latter part of the wedding changing
water to 800 liters of wine for a
wedding
i don't think that's how he would work
no no
so it was definitely unfermented because
the fermented wine would be a symbol of
sin because fermentation was used as a
symbol of sin
so all of those things need to be
understood in the contents
the feeding of the five thousand
embraces humanity
so that's a very important
miracle that is mentioned over there
and he's feeding them with the bread of
life
it was a symbol of the bread of life a
symbol of himself
and the number five is the number of
humanity you have five senses
so that embraced all of humanity being
fed by the bread of life the walking on
the sea
the sea in in prophecy represents
peoples nations multitudes
kingdoms
so he's the one who is the master of the
sea he is actually the owner of the
universe he is above the common laws of
nature
he's not subject to them
he's above them so this is part of his
rulership part of his
his
divinity
then the royal official son is an
example of undaunted faith in the word
so here's a royal official
who believed and said it's not necessary
for you to even come to my house just
say the word
and my son will be healed
and this is this is undaughted faith and
this is the kind of faith that he
required of his people
it's interesting that it's very often
those that were not part of his people
like
roman officials and centurions
that were the perfect example of what
faith entailed yes they got it right
they got it right
then the lame man at bethesda and the
stirring of the water addresses the
superstitions of the professed believers
we can look into those sort of
issues as well
the healing of the blind man is a
witness to the church leaders
and then the raising of lazarus crowns
them all yeah so this is basically
what
the emphasis of john is
to show the divinity but there are other
things in john that we need to
look at very careful
the question is why no parables
there are parables in all the synoptic
gospels why no parables in the book of
john
i believe it's because jesus said that
the parables are for the uninformed but
to his people he speaks plainly
the parables are a brilliant way of
teaching
without being so direct as to cause
major consternation you say something in
a parable then you get the message in
obliquely yes and also it is
sometimes for some people
more
better explained through a parable they
probably wouldn't understand it it's
like an object lesson
exactly
so in john 16 verse 25 you read these
things have i spoken unto you in
proverbs but the time cometh when i
shall no more speak unto you in prophets
but i will show you plainly of the
father
so the gospel of john is
plain talk
it is a very direct testimony
and it's interesting that that is the
testimony that enraged the pharisees and
the jewish leaders
but there's also very plain talk to the
disciples
that we will come to
now if we look at the the structure of
the book so the first 13 chapters deal
with these issues
but many of these happened in the very
last portion of the ministry of christ
chapter 13 to 17 of the gospel of john
deals with the last hours of the life of
jesus so a substantial portion of the
book
deals with just the last hours yes
interesting that the spirit of prophecy
also says you should spend
a thoughtful hour every day on the last
hours of jesus yes so it's good that we
must do that right
and then
there are special instructions given to
his chosen followers
and the remaining chapters deal with the
crucifixion resurrection and the events
before the ascension of jesus
so there's a substantial portion
that was given to the disciples
on the last day
in the last portion of a day
so after judas had departed not one of
those that were left was to be lost
it's interesting
jesus departed yes
and the others are all
in the book of life
they were the ones who were to receive
the early rain
and so i believe it will be in the end
the latter rain will fall on those who
have been purged of the judas syndrome
so when judas left
that what remained
received the early reign
at the end of time when judas
leaves
the company of the believers
those that remain
will receive the latter reign
so
you'll have a mini or this was a mini
shaking
this was a shaking
and also god
removes the tares yes he said
to judas do what you
do quickly
you see judas has made a decision in his
heart
god knew about the decision and he
didn't prevent him that's it because he
knew he wasn't going to turn him around
so he said whatever you're going to do
just do it quickly
and and the disciples didn't know what
he was talking about
they thought he had to go and get
something or whatever
now
after this purging
they received a message for their ears
only
there was no judas left in the company
it was not preached to the multitude but
was for their encouragement it was to
equip them for their task of preaching
the message with power
it was information that set them apart
and fortified them against the errors of
the scribes and the pharisees in other
words they had to be so settled in the
truth that they could not be moved
that's it that's called sealing martin
ceiling time ceiling time
in the same way we need to be inoculated
against these errors
every wind of doctrine will be blowing
and in the midst of this you need to
cling to very sound instruction
i believe we are living in this time we
are sitting right now at the last supper
very soon
there will be a shaking
judas will get up from the table and
will leave
there are people that say no the
disciples must leave and judas must stay
yeah no it's not that way around it's
the other way around
laodicea
doesn't have a coming out no
it has a spewing out that's it
what you do go and do it quickly
judas must leave judas must leave will
judas be an accusing brethren oh
definitely
and you might regret it later but it
will he'll be an accusing brethren and
he will bring the leaders
for persecution towards you
this is all interesting typology we need
to understand it we need to
spend a contemplative hour
john 17 verse 12
while i was with them in the world i
kept them in thy name
those that thou gaveth me
i have kept
and none of them is lost
but the son of perdition that the
scripture might be fulfilled
those that received the former reign
those 11 disciples none of them were
lost it says so that's it
except the son of perdition the judas
principle he left
so let's look at the statement in the
spirit of prophecy as to
what we can expect when we study john
this one quotes the book of john so we
need to study the word in the knowledge
that god is speaking to us
directly it's important that when you
read
you
must have faith that you are reading the
word of god
that's very important
like we i think we've stated that quite
clearly in past
episodes how important the true word of
god you can't emphasize it enough you
must have confidence that what you are
reading is the word of god
and you must have confidence
that god preserved his word
so let's read this quote
those only who read the scriptures as
the voice of god speaking to them are
true learners
they tremble at the voice of god for
them at ease a living reality they open
their understanding to divine
instruction and pray for grace
that they may obtain a preparation
for service
the latter rain is that a preparation
for service definitely
that's the preparation for
the most important work
that can be done on this earth
as the heavenly torch is placed in his
hand the seeker for truth sees his own
frailty
his infirmity the hopelessness of
looking to himself for righteousness
that's beautifully put that embraces all
the writings of paul yeah
he sees that there is in him nothing
that can recommend him to god let's just
go back to those early disciples
at that last supper
they had three and a half years
instruction in the university of christ
yes
and they were perfect right
no they were pathetic yes so maybe we're
pathetic too right exactly
they were arguing on the way to the last
supper as to who was the greatest yes
they were
arguing about who will sit on his left
and right side correct
so they were full of themselves
and they hadn't realized their
hopelessness and their nothingness yes
that they had nothing to recommend
themselves
and he prays for the holy spirit the
representative of christ to be his
constant guide to lead him into all
truth
he repeats the promise the comforter
which is the holy ghost whom the father
will send in my name he shall teach you
all things quoting john 14 26
so this is how we must approach this
book
this is a final instruction
by the god of the universe
for those who will be his
representatives
so how important can it be it's
unbelievable unbelievable unbelievable
here's another quote from the review and
hero the will of god in regard to his
people is plainly expressed
in the 6th
13th
14th
15th 16th
17th chapters of john
now that's the portion
where jesus speaks to his disciples
intensely
instructing them as to
what is important in terms of their
mission
and then come the chapters that deal
with the crucifixion itself
so we need to understand the 6th the
13th the 14th the 15th the 16th the 17th
chapter of john
the divine antidote for the sin of the
whole world is contained in the gospel
of john
who so eateth my flesh and drinketh my
blood christ declared has eternal life
and i will raise him up at the last day
so if we do not internalize the
character of christ which is embodied in
obedience to all of god's requirements
then we have missed the boat and it also
refers to the last day so these words
that
jesus gave to the disciples there
is tip a lot typologically for us
going towards the last day
that's why we need to study it
he may die as christ died
but the life of the savior is in him his
life is hid with christ in god
i am come that they may have life jesus
said and that they may have it more
abundantly he carries on the great
process
by which believers are made one with him
in this present life to be one with him
throughout all
eternity
so you know some people may die
but if you have christ in you
then you are not dead you have eternal
life yeah
i was thinking the other day
when god said the day you eat of it
you will surely die
that was actually
a proclamation of
mercy because the devil hates those that
have accepted christ as their personal
savior and he hounds them
and he follows them
and he tries to destroy them and he
makes their life a misery so this this
walk this earthly walk
has its pitfalls right
and then you get older
and you get tired and eventually you get
so old and tired that you wish you could
go to sleep so
then death becomes a mercy right
and once you are asleep
nobody can get hold of you anymore
nobody can hound you
nobody can persecute you
they can throw tantrums
they can go and dig up the bones of
wycliffe
grind them burn them grind them to a
pulp throw them into a river in a fit of
rage
doesn't help them because wycliffe
doesn't know anything about it he's
totally at peace resting in christ
while all around them are throwing
tantrums right not even the taxman can
get hold of you anymore nobody can get
hold of you
it's actually a merciful situation yes
and when that day of resurrection comes
what a day it will be
there are those today
who will present falsehoods as testing
truths even as the jews presented the
maxims of men as the bread of heaven
sayings of no value are given to the
people of god as their portion of meat
while souls are starving for the bread
of life
fables have been devised and men are
trying to weave these fables into the
web
those who do this will one day
see their work as it is viewed by the
heavenly intelligences they choose to
bring to the foundation wood hay and
stubble
when they have it they command the word
of god
with all its richness and power from
which they can gather precious treasures
of truth
how important is that statement for the
times we are living in
absolutely important
how many falsehoods do we have how many
winds of doctrine are blowing
even within the church
and if you don't cling to the word of
god
no you you'll get up and walk that's it
but it is judas that got up and walked
yeah
there's another statement from the
review narrow the food that is being
prepared for the flock of god will cause
spiritual consumption decline and death
when those who profess to believe
present truth come to their senses
when they accept the word of god just as
it reads
when they do not try to rest the
scriptures they will bring from the
treasure house of the heart things new
and old to strengthen themselves and
those for whom they labor
we have to be
word-based christians
there are those who say
not only in their hearts but in all
their works my lord delays is coming
that's another big problem right
remember it's the wicked servant that
says my lord delays his coming
because christ's coming has been long
foretold they conclude that there is
some mistake in regard to it
but the lord says the vision is yet for
an appointed time but at the end it
shall speak and not lie
though it tarry wait for it because it
will surely come it will not tarry past
the time that the message is born to all
nations tongues and people
shall we who claim to be students of
prophecy forget that god's forbearance
to the wicked is part of the vast and
merciful plan by which he is seeking to
compass the salvation of souls
shall we be found amongst the number who
having ceased to cooperate with god are
found saying my lord delays he's coming
martin i hope we don't fall into that
trap
but that we continue to say
he's coming and he's coming to the door
he's at the door
and you know that's why we need to have
a balance
we need to have a balance between what's
happening in the world
we're at the door that's it
but also
what is the spiritual fortification
that we need for when he is at the door
absolutely
i think it's time we started diving into
the book of john right yes the gospel of
jesus those chapters that we are munched
to
yes study let's just briefly go through
some of the others as well
so when we read the gospel of john
then immediately we see what the burden
of john is
and it starts as we have said a number
of times already with in the beginning
what other book starts with that again
martin genesis genesis
i love these little
little connections that we find in the
beginning
was the word and the word was with god
and the word
was god
and then it talks about the witness
and that that witness was john the
baptist
and he testified
and in verse 11
which by the way is the beginning of a
new paragraph
it says
he came unto his own and his own
received him not but as many as received
him to them he gave gave he power to
become the sons of god
even to them that believe in his name
which were born not of blood nor of the
will of the flesh nor of the will of man
but of god
so let's not be presumptuous
we are saved because god calls us
because we've all gone astray
and it is god that calls us back so all
honor and glory
go to him
and the word was made flesh and dwelt
amongst us and we beheld his glory the
glory of the only begotten of the father
full of grace and truth
now this is john writing he's one of the
sons of thunder
what changed him
only jesus could okay he beheld his
glory yeah
the divinity of jesus
he saw
that he
was god he saw that he was god but what
what did he see did he see a glorious
being shining with light yes he saw it
once
at the transfiguration
he saw this glorious shining being but
what did he perceive before he saw the
glorious shining being and before his
character was changed what did he
perceive he saw a man that came from
poverty
he saw an unpretentious person
he saw a kind person
he saw a gentle person
he saw a person that had tremendous
patience
he saw a suffering person
he saw the way in which he dealt with
his suffering
and he marveled
and he thought to himself after a while
i wish i could be like that
i'm a son of thunder
and i wish i could be
like that so what he what he saw was the
character of christ
that's it and he
saw
also the meekness
because if you're a son of thunder
meekness is not your not a very big
virtue
you've always flame up and you've got a
short fuse
i
i can relate to that where the way you
have did you have a short fuse
yeah
just as short as i am
so
what did the lord give your wife to sort
out your short future yes you gave me a
lightning conductor
your poor wife
and then it says john bear witness of
him and cried saying this was he of whom
i spake he that cometh after me is
preferred before me for he was before me
so who was older john or jesus john he
was older by six months yes he was older
but he says jesus was before him so he
must have recognized something right
yes
and of his fullness have all we received
and grace for grace for the law was
given by moses
but grace and truth came by jesus christ
so basically what he's saying is
the law
the books of moses
the pentateuch
foreshadowed jesus and what he would do
for us but the reality the substance was
manifested in christ now
beautiful right
so basically chapter one
deals with who christ is
that he is god
and then if we drop down to verse 35
it says again the next day
after john stood and two of his
disciples and looked upon jesus as he
walked he said behold the lamb of god
and the two disciples heard him speak
and they followed jesus
then jesus turned and saw them following
and said unto them what seek ye
they said unto him rabbi which is to say
being interpreted master
where dwelleth thou
and he said unto them come and see
they came and saw where he dwelt and
abode with him that day for it was about
the tenth hour
and one of the two which heard john
speak and followed him was andrew
simon peter's brother
and he findeth his own brother simon and
so it continued this one found that one
and that one found that one and the two
of them eventually found this one and
someone found nathaniel and so
one after the other
they came through the witness of what
some saw
through what john saw
they came to christ right
and all jesus says
come and see
so he's not telling them anything no
come and come and see for yourself come
see for yourself
see what it's all about
so that's the burden of chapter one
we want to get
to the instructions
that are important for our time so we're
not going to do a verse by verse
exposition of the book of john
then in chapter 2
you have
the
cleansing the turning of the water into
wine
now we've talked about that already so
that's a very important
message
that the real cleansing comes through
the blood of the lamb
chapter 3 deals with nicodemus
and that you have to be born again
you have to get a spiritual insight
and this discussion is is is fascinating
it deals with so many aspects it deals
with uh who jesus is
so if we just look at verse seven it
says marvel not that i said unto thee ye
must be born again
there needs to be a spiritual birth
if you drop down to verse 14
he says and as moses lifted up the
serpent in the wilderness even so must
the son of man be lifted up
that was an important clue and and
nicodemus internalized that
and when the crucifixion took place he
understood
that christ had become sin
for us
the disciples ran away
but nicodemus remembered this statement
of jesus
and they are very important lessons that
follow whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have eternal life
verse 16 for god so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life
for god sent not his son into the world
to condemn the world
but that the world through him might be
saved those are probably the most famous
verses in the whole of the gospel of
john
maybe the bible even
well it's the summary of the entire
character of god in the bible
it is the difference
between true religion and false religion
any religion that doesn't embrace that
has a wrong
concept of the character of god
which is sad that's it
now after we've read
what jesus told nicodemus
and this is so important
because in verse 18 he says to nicodemus
he that believeth on him is not
condemned but he that believeth not is
condemned already because he has not
believed in the name of the only
begotten son of god
that's dealing with the character the
name deals with the character
you have no concept of what god is all
about if you don't understand jesus
this is the burden of john
the son of thunder who looks at jesus
and realizes that his character falls
for far short but it's important like
you just said to realize he's talking
about the character
not the pronunciation of his name
now jesus is saying these things because
if you if you read it here in the gospel
of john the the words are in red
jesus speaking let's get another witness
now we turn to john
drop down to verse 22
and verse 23
they are
bold in my in my bible in other words
this is a new paragraph
so verse 22 after these things
came jesus and his disciples into the
land of judea
and there he tarried with them and
baptized and john
also was baptizing
in anon near salim because there was
much water there and they came and were
baptized
for john was not yet cast into prison
and then interesting in verse 25 which
is again a new paragraph there arose a
question between some of john's
disciples and the jews about purifying
that's interesting
because jesus has just explained to
nicodemus how one is purified
you have to be born again yes
and the purification is not something
that you do through your ritualistic
endeavors but through the blood of
christ
so this dispute arises and they consult
john
now john doesn't go into details and
tells them what they must do and how
many times they must wash and all of
these things but he gives a witness
under the
full power of the holy spirit
and he says in verse 30 referring to
christ he must increase but i
must decrease
that cometh from above is above all he
that is of the earth is earthly and
speakers of the earth he that cometh
from heaven is above all
and what he has seen and heard that he
testifies and no man receiveth his
testimony
interesting so here john is saying
that jesus is from heaven
and that he is above all things and has
full knowledge about the godhead because
he himself is god
and then
he says no man receives his testimony
so if the spirit doesn't convince you no
you won't get there exactly you have to
be born again
i just want to mention that we mustn't
get confused here
this john that is speaking here is john
the baptist
yes
it's not john that wrote
the gospel correct it's not john that
wrote the gospel that he's speaking here
he's quoting john the baptist
remember that they were disciples of
john the baptist
and here john is saying an interesting
thing if we read from verse 34 it says
for him
for he whom god has sent speaketh the
words of god
for god give us not the spirit by
measure unto him
the father loveth the son and has given
all things into his hand
he that believeth on the son has
everlasting life and he that believeth
not the son shall not see life but the
wrath of god abideth in him that is a
powerful testimony
by john the baptist
because he brings out how important it
is
to have faith without seeing
now immediately after this
conversation
in chapter 3
where you have the witness of jesus to
nicodemus
and you have the confirmation of that
witness by john the baptist
in chapter four
you have the woman at the well in
samaria
so you're moving from god's people and
their representatives nicodemus
and those that were listening to the
message of john the baptist
you move to the despised samaritans
the story is in the gospel of john
to show that jesus is no respecter of
persons
unlike what the jews would have done
the next story deals with this woman and
a woman is typologically a symbol of the
church
so god's church includes all of humanity
even the despised samaritans
and this woman when she recognized jesus
as the messiah
she ran to a city and said come and see
a man who told me all things about
myself
one who knows everything this is the
messiah she had not one
iota of doubt
and it just shows how all embracing
god's love is yes i think you hit
the nail on the head and this is the
first time that jesus actually
says plainly
that he is the messiah
this is unbelievable he didn't say it to
nicodemus
he didn't say it to anyone else he said
it to a samaritan woman he actually
didn't say it to the ones that were
supposed to know it yes and it says here
in verse 25 and 26 the woman says unto
him i know that messiah's cometh
which is called christ when he is come
he will tell us all things jesus said
unto him i that speak unto thee am he
unbelievable
to a samaritan woman he says i am the
messiah
what does that tell us about evangelism
that you don't have to hold back
you have to go to the world
that does not know about the messiah
that does not have this word and tell
them jesus is the messiah that's what
you have to tell them
so martin there's a work to be done
because the greatest portion of humanity
denies that christ is the messiah
let's drop down to chapter five in
chapter five we have this interesting
story that takes place at the pool of
bethesda
where this lame impotent man had been
laying for
years
that's a very interesting time period
because those 38 years represent the
wandering of the children of israel in
the desert
when they had to return after having
come to canaan
they could have entered in but they did
not enter in
they wandered for 40 years remember but
two had passed already and they were
turned back for another 38 years because
they did not believe
because they had their superstitious
ways and did not trust god's word
completely
so here was this impotent man who had
been lying there
all this time
so he was a symbol of the unbelieving
wandering
jews
destitute in the wilderness experience
that they were in
and he's lying at this pool
and they believed that the water would
be stirred when an angel came down
and this was a superstition that they
had
and jesus addresses him
and says
will thou be made whole
and the man says i have no one.
that's a rather sad statement right i
have no one
no one all the other
holy ones
as they perceived themselves were around
there nobody helped him nobody helped
him he had no one
and god
set the record straight and it was on
the sabbath day
this enraged the jews
it set up the controversy and the
conflict between true worship and false
worship
is there a lesson in it for us today no
definitely
are there rituals in the world where
people believe that certain
things will happen if you do certain
particular things
if you go through rituals if you go
through rituals or you go to a
particular faith healer and
you trust that
when you
are able to go to a particular place
like lords or wherever there your
probability of being healed is so much
greater than if you stayed at home
how ridiculous is god not everywhere
do you have to undergo a pilgrimage to a
specific spot in order to find his grace
no it's a false religion
so what jesus does
in chapter five is he addresses false
religion
so this healing that we had at the pool
of bethesda
was a very very important pivotal point
because it created the opportunity
not only for enlightenment
but out of the conflict that arose
between jesus and the pharisees
the truth was presented to them
and they could either accept it or
reject it yeah for after all a great
miracle had taken place right they had a
witness yet so many things happening at
the same time
simultaneously like you mentioned
it was he was standing between this man
and the pool
not even looking at the pool not even
looking at the pool he was ignoring the
pool because the pool was a
superstitious belief system
that they had embraced which denied the
power of god
and relied on human strength to go and
crawl into that pool so they showed i am
the
the healer look at me yes and then
secondly what also he did is he did it
on the sabbath yes to show them
that he's the healer and lord of the
sabbath correct that's why it says in
verse 17
and therefore did the jews persecute
jesus and sought to slay him because he
had done these things on the sabbath day
and then he enraged them because he said
but jesus answered them
my father worketh hitherto and i work
therefore the jews sought the more to
kill him because he not only had broken
the sabbath but said also that god was
his father making himself equal with god
they fully understood what he said yes
that he was god and can you now say that
he broke the law he broke the sabbath
law how can he break the law if he is
lord of the sabbath
so he didn't break it he broke it
according to them yes according to their
human
dictates will there be a similar case
exactly that's what i want to do will
there be a human law
which will be contrary to god's law
worthy of pronouncing the death sentence
of on someone who doesn't keep the human
law yeah
we're heading for the same situation
martin
and then jesus answered
and he said the following verily verily
i say unto you the son can do nothing of
himself but what he sees the father do
for what things soever he doeth
these also doeth the son likewise
they have the same power
they have the same authority they have
the same
mindset
and then he continues for the father
loveth the son and shows them all things
that himself doeth and he will show him
greater works than these that ye may
marvel
now he's talking about the works they
just witnessed
a tremendous miracle
for as the father raises up the dead and
quickeneth them even so the son
quickeneth whom he will
for the father judges no man but has
committed all judgment unto the son
that all men should honor the son even
as they honor the father he that
honoreth not the son
honoreth not the father which hath sent
him you can only come to the father
through christ
and
in christ is the only means whereby you
can understand the father
if you see the son
you have seen the father
he continues and says verily verily i
send to you he that heareth my word and
believeth on him that sent me has
everlasting life and shall not come into
condemnation but is passed from death
unto life here's a theological sermon
on salvation that's it and who is he
giving it to to the leaders to the
leaders yes so this confrontation was
brought about to bring a theological
reality and a discourse
to the jews
to the leaders
how would they react
furious furious
and then he
then he confirms that he's the
resurrection and the life verily verily
i say unto you the hour is coming and
now is when the dead shall hear the
voice of the son of god and they that
here shall live for as the father has
life in himself so he has given to the
son to have life within himself
and has given him authority to execute
judgment also because he is the son of
man
the son of man is a title
that you find in the book of daniel
i saw one like the son of man come to
the ancient of days this is a judgment
scene that takes place in heaven
so these two subtitles son of god son of
man are unique to christ that's it
marvel not at this for the hour is
coming in which all that i in the grave
shall hear his voice and shall come
forth they that have done good unto the
resurrection of life and they that have
done evil unto the resurrection of
damnation so he's giving them a
theological lesson
and he's
infuriating the sadducees who don't
believe in the resurrection
he's got everybody covered there all
right so do we have similar religions
today
they might believe they might not
believe in a resurrection but they
believe in a reincarnation
here is theology at its best it tells us
what the position of the sun is it tells
us all judgment is given unto him it
tells us that the power of the
resurrection is
in his word that he will raise them up
on the last day that there are two
resurrections
in this place it doesn't tell us that
they're separated by a thousand years
but later in the book of
revelation
we
get to understand that
also
now if we read verse 31 martin
it says if i bear witness of myself my
witness is not true
because you need more than one witness
right
now this is very important
there's another that beareth witness of
me
and i know that the witness which he
witnesses of me is true
ye sent unto john and he bear witness
unto the truth
but i received not testimony from man
but these things i say that you might be
saved
he was burning he was a burning and a
shining light and ye were willing for a
season to rejoice in his light
so he just performed the mighty miracle
he's bearing witness of himself
to them and he's saying all right you
don't want to accept my testimony that i
am the way the truth and the life i am
the one
that has the power of resurrection at my
disposal because i and the father are
one we are god they just
recognized that he'd said that
now he brings in the witness of john
and he says john testified of these
things and we read it just now this in
the previous where john testified of
these things
then he says in verse 36
but i have greater witness
than that of john
for the works which the father has given
me to finish the same works that i do
bear witness of me and the father has
sent me so there's another witness
and the father himself which has sent me
has
borne witness of me
ye have neither heard his voice at any
time nor seen his shape
and ye
and ye have not his word abiding in you
for whom he has sent
him ye believe not
so martin he's saying that there are a
number of witnesses that testify to the
fact that he is who he claims to be
one he talks about himself
he says all right you say that witness
is not true because i'm testifying of
myself
but what about john
yes you were happy to abide in his light
he testified of exactly the same thing
but you won't believe him now
yes because you don't want to believe me
behold
the lamb of god then he says what about
the works
the works testify that i am who i claim
to be have you ever seen a man lamb get
up and walk just by my word on the
sabbath day that you are contesting and
saying i'm a law breaker because of that
whereas i am showing you i am lord of
the sabbath i am your creator and you
keep the sabbath because i said that i
created the earth the heavens and
everything in them in six days
but you won't acknowledge me as the
creator god if i give
life to someone who is
dead
for 38 years in a sense
and then the father he says testified
where did the father testify
at the baptism at the baptism this is my
beloved son in whom i am well pleased
and the people heard him
so there was a witness from heaven
there was a witness on earth john the
baptist the works testify and then he
says in verse 39 search the scriptures
for in them you think you have eternal
life and they are they which testify of
me so there are four witnesses
john testified the works testified the
father testified and the scriptures
testified there's no doubt
about
this issue
so now imagine that we have
laid the groundwork
for the message that is to come to god's
people
to prepare them for the latter reign
which is ensconced in the message
to the disciples who were to receive the
former rain
i think we should take a break
and do this in another episode we'll
continue
later thank you let's do that will you
pray for us yes
heavenly father
the riches
and the beauty
of the gospel of john
that has these four great witnesses that
testify to the truth
and doesn't even include the witness of
the disciples at this stage
sets the stage for what is coming
may we
internalize these words
make them our own
believe them with all our heart and with
all our mind because the testimony is
true based on the witnesses
and maybe be ready
when the time comes
when that final conflict takes place
this is my prayer in jesus name amen
[Music]
you